[Musique]
alors attention on va voir on a préparé
vous allez voir ya une roue et vous
allez voir qui vous a limité à chaque
fois c'est parti
la battle d'imitation attention alors
dans cette classe et une battle un donc
philippe lellouche donc patrick bruel
contre fils il a chaud qui va imiter van
damme cet appel d'imitation elle n'est
pas du tout ce qu'est la roue ne réserve
pas de moi tu rêve depuis longtemps
envahi l'écran
[Applaudissements]
parce que tu peux faire patrick bruel
qui reprend une chanson de charles
aznavour
ah oui il a fait le pouls et ennui
mokolo avant ce ventre alourdi de free
les bateaux est ce que tu peux faire à
ce d'amour qui me wade qui pêchait sur
l'épisode qui nous regardent bourvil
c'est comme fifi voilà et bachir accès
comme bacon voila voila si comme ça
c'était getti van damme c'est à toi
c'est horrible je sais pas le faire mais
déjà perdu ses prix c'est ni faire le
grand écart d'illimité battu le
remplacer que boulou gfr bénéfique aux
attentes mais n'a pas voulu s'y fait que
je me faut changer les images
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les van damme tu peux le faire fait
colonne est même pas une phrase il en a
l'habitude non mais c'est le petit
mousse dans cette affaire j'ai pas
compris
là on doit dire qu'il ya mieux fait
brûler ce que tu peux faire beaucoup et
qui chante du patrimoine
[Musique]
[Rires]
ouais je donne quand même le point s'il
pleut c'est très bien vu du niveau
l'accord match étriqué ouais ouais
d'accord
ah oui ah oui d'accord donc ludivine
céline dion et moi je dois faire jean
luc reichmann toi c'est facile tu es
déjà une tâche si tellement calmes
d'être là ne partez pas c'était des gens
hystériques
mon frère est né en race à l'abus elle a
appris que moi ce que j'adore c'est la
photo de settat photo cyril là c'est
vraiment la photo qui ont réussis tu
faisais d'immobilier ont fait
[Applaudissements]
nicolas n'avait pas de visa vide il ya
un énorme potentiel mon imitation
ah oui la question
la question coquine
en france ont déjà fait ça donne quoi
d'abou mazen
j'aime bien j'ai bien j'espère que ça va
retomber bagatelle mall et nicolas
sarkozy il doit me faire
ah bah je sais pas si un passif on va
démarrer par toi basique atteler jamais
fait vas-y met alors à temps mais je
suis embêté parce qu'il le fait
tellement bien felipe mon premier
facteur après je vais faire la vérité
j'ai tout à fait des trucs de kader mais
je vais faire la classe je vais faire la
version moi le fait d'en diriger du
maroc s'est achevée vers enrico macias
est terrible parce que je sais pas bien
le faire il le fait tellement de l'arête
de foot
écoutez je sais mais bientôt les nerfs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si la monnaie c'est d'abord un plaisir
d'être ici à cette émission c'est très
bien une émission qui il te le dit
personnellement mais l'ouverture aux
autres
je sais pas et je vous dire monsieur
hanouna ya plein d'endroits où j'ai pas
forcément mis des pieds verts content de
venir vous voir pour deux raisons socio
nina je vais vous dire c'est quand on a
peur du vent monte pas en haut de
l'arbre
et là moi j'ai envie de venir dans une
émission les gens vous regardent
ouais c'est tout voilà
[Applaudissements]
si jamais fait non plus déjà jouer les
cons s'est jamais fait un bond et jette
un thème même dit que sarkozy c'est vrai
c'est toujours comme ça de pris
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
k
oh
c'est ça
bravo
[Applaudissements]